[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome to this afternoon's webinar
my name is greg wilson i work for
rstudio on the education team
and we've put this one together to help
everybody who is finding themselves
moving their teaching
online at short notice i'd like to thank
robert and curtis for setting up all of
the mechanics for this
and there is a question tab in go to
webinar
please throw questions into it at any
time during the presentation we'll field
some of them during the call
and we'll gather up the rest at the end
all right let's get rolling because it's
a it's a big world in a short day
so you all plaid plans you all had some
idea of
how you were going to teach a course
this semester how you were going to
deliver that training workshop
and now all of a sudden you find
yourself in an off-road vehicle at night
we've all of us been thrown off our
plans in the last couple of weeks
and quite reasonably a lot of us are
afraid that things are going to
crash out bad right we're here to help
what we're going to do in the next 45
minutes is give you a few tips that
we hope will help you move your teaching
online
without crashing it's not the best you
could possibly do
it's what you can do in a hurry with the
tools you've got and the time you have
because
like your learners you're probably now
wrestling with a whole bunch of issues
around looking after kids or elderly
parents travel plans being cancelled
everybody and their cousin being on
bandwidth at the same time
we're hoping that these tips will help
you get through that now
this is the persona i had in mind when i
developed this
deck emily's pre-tenure faculty also
teaches
in industry she's comfortable using
modern tools she facetimes with her
partner all the time
she struggles a bit with her school's
learning management system but
you know that's blackboard's fault
that's not hers and now she's got to
move a class of 80 people online in a
week
so that they can finish semester more or
less on time and she's also got a couple
of workshops that she signed contracts
for
she really doesn't want to have to
cancel out of those and
above all of this she is afraid that
whatever happens in the next few weeks
is just going to suck a lot of time away
from research and she's a year away from
applying for tenure and i put this
concept map together in order to figure
out what i was going to cover
i wound up covering more than this so
i'm going to skip and go to the first
and most important rule and if you take
one thing away from today's talk i want
it to be this
don't change what you don't have to now
there's an old saying if you're going on
a long walk you wear old shoes
you don't wear new shoes if you've got a
long way to go please
don't try to change 19 different things
about your class
because you've heard that the right way
to teach online is to use x or do y
right now running late running without
extra resources
what we want to look for is the smallest
possible changes we can make
and that's what i'm going to be focusing
on okay
the second rule and this one comes from
elizabeth wicks at the university of
illinois
please don't make assumptions please ask
your learners your students your
colleagues
they aren't going to have the same
bandwidth that you have
their network might not be as reliable
their computer at home might be a
six-year-old hand-me-down because
they're no longer at the university
in a corporate environment it might be
the very first time they've had to use
stuff over a vpn
because they're used to going into the
office and
they may not have the attention span
they used to because of
all of these pandemic induced
distractions
so rule number two go and ask them
nobody will ever be offended if you say
what kind of device are you on how much
time do you realistically have
the next recommendation i've got is
please don't try to be
or to beat the kind of recorded video
you see
in polished produced courses on sites
like edx
it takes a lot of time to edit up even a
simple
video and it takes a lot of time to
learn the tools you use for editing
those videos
you probably don't have that time right
now i'm not saying that recorded video
doesn't have its place
we're going to record this webinar and
make it available to people
but right now i think in the short run
your best bet
is to try to use things interactively
and worry about recording and editing
and publishing video
later if
you're going to ignore my advice and go
ahead and start doing it
there's a really good paper from 2009 by
chen and rabb called a pattern language
for screencasting
they take a lot of apparently
straightforward ideas
and organize them in a sensible way
their concept map is up here on the
screen there's
just a whole bunch of good tips here
about what makes for a good screencast
what makes for a good online video and
how the parts fit together so you know
what not to do or what not to venture
into
all of these slides by the way are going
to be available after the talk
so if you haven't copied down that url
don't worry you'll be able to find it
later
next thing i'm going to say is the
mistakes for the pedagogy
depending on whose numbers you trust a
professional programmer spends twenty to
sixty percent of their time debugging
a novice spends eighty to ninety five
percent of their time debugging because
they're a novice
the same is going to be true in most
areas
so please don't worry about making
mistakes
in front of your learners when you're
teaching online for the first or the
second or the third time
because every time you make a mistake
and then say oh
this is wrong here's how i can tell
here's how i figured out how to fix it
and here's how i can tell it's been
fixed
they will have learned something
valuable and this comes back to the
larger point
that when you're teaching online
interactively when you're doing what i'm
doing right now
you learn the song but then you
improvise over it
i've got a slide deck it has speakers
notes i'm really glad that i prepped all
of that because it got me to think
through the things i'm going to say but
now what i'm actually saying on any
given day
is going to be partly improvised it's
going to depend on the feedback that i'm
getting from my audience it's going to
depend on
thoughts that i have now that i'm
presenting and that's okay
the better you know your material the
more comfortable you will be improvising
but don't think that you have to stick
to exactly what you planned the night
before
the corollary to this is it's really
really
hard to teach to a room full of empty
chairs
all of us all the time are picking up
social cues
we're constantly peripherally aware of
whether somebody is nodding
or whether they're checking their phone
did they just yawn
or are they thinking because they're
about to ask a question you might not
notice that you're noticing but you
notice
and as soon as you start teaching online
a lot of that is taken away
if you take all of it away you're going
to find it very very difficult to teach
what i suggest you do is get your
students
into some sort of webinar like this
but then have a few of them turn on
their video
so that you can see a few people if
for example you're using zoom which is
my preferred video conferencing tool
pick a half a dozen names at random and
ask them to turn on video
and then focus your attention on those
six
ask them your questions pay attention to
their faces just as you would in a real
class
and in your next class pick a different
half dozen
this teaching practice predates video
it was quite common it still is in some
places if you've got a large class
to pick a few people bring them down
front and
focus your teaching on them for this
hour but then focus it on a different
half dozen for the next hour
and so on they get individual attention
you get the kind of responsiveness you
need to make
improvisation and teaching lively
and everybody else now has permission to
turn off their video
and reduce the load on the system if
you're going to do this
please give people a way to opt out
for a whole bunch of reasons a lot of
people are uncomfortable being
on video online if you've ever had to
deal with harassment or a stalker
you don't want images of yourself
appearing that might go out of your
control
people have many other issues if they're
working at home for the first time for
example
maybe they don't want others to be able
to see the mess in the background the
kids playing and so on
so invite people don't mandate it but
try to get
as i said four five or six people that
you're directing your teaching to
that will keep you engaged and you'll do
a better job with the teaching
the next one was recommended by one of
my colleagues
and i'm embarrassed that i didn't think
of it because it reveals my expert blind
spot
the first time you move your class
online give them a tour
of the tool that you're using they
probably haven't seen
zoom or whatever you've got they might
not know
where to click the button to mute seems
obvious once you know
it's anything but if you've just been
thrown into it
so taking 10 minutes at the start of
your first online lecture
to show people how you're expecting them
to use the tool
or taking an hour beforehand to take a
few screenshots
and then share those with the class can
save a lot of grief
if you're going to do this make sure
that you're logged in
as a normal user not as the teacher or
the conference organizer
when you're giving the tool because if
you're logged in as a super user
you will see a different set of tools
that they don't have
and that will confuse them
the next one up is to direct traffic
you don't have to go full north korean
that's where this picture is from
but again for a lot of people this is
their first time being
in some sort of structured formal
setting online
so always give them verbal cues
ask them to put their questions in the
chat
ask them to add their answers to a
homework question
to the shared google doc call on them by
name
when you want them to speak or ask them
to type something like
slash hand or raise hand in the chat
when they want
to speak make sure that
they're all getting direction about what
they're supposed to do next
after a while you can dial that down
but i have found in my own teaching that
i don't
i constantly do it because i've
constantly got people who are
new or who are coming in from somebody
else's class where they might have
evolved
a different set of conventions whatever
it is
you as the tour guide telling people now
we're moving on to the renaissance arts
section
everybody step this way again
it takes away a lot of the uncertainty
and right now people have got enough
uncertainty to deal with
one other point on this mute early and
mute often
by default now when i'm in zoom after
somebody finishes speaking
i don't wait for them to mute i don't
even mute them
i instinctively now hit the mute all
button
i put everybody back in a muted state
even if they don't need to be
because that way i never forget to
you can do a very good class audio only
or audio with slides video is helpful
but it's not essential and i can prove
this by asking
what would happen if we left you with
video with me talking right now but
turned off the sound
you wouldn't learn anything you've got
to make sure that everybody can be heard
you've got to make sure that you're not
drowned out by feedback by background
noise
or crucially by somebody who constantly
wants to be the next one to ask the
question who constantly wants to jump in
first
one thing that i do to ensure that
is i actually keep a written list of
names beside me of the people that i'm
focusing my teaching on that half dozen
i referred to earlier
every time i interact with them i just
put a tick beside their name
so that i can very quickly see who i
have been talking to
and who i haven't been talking to that
way i can distribute my attention more
or less fairly
among those half dozen and if somebody
is constantly trying to jump in
i can say no it's not your turn we're
trying to take turns here
if you are relying on people to unmute
themselves
and just jump in with their questions
your class is going to be dominated by a
couple of extroverts
and everybody else will very quickly
learn to not even bother to try to ask
questions
or to contribute ideas because they can
never get in fast enough
mute early mute often and then have
people request the microphone in order
to speak
so that you do the unmuting and as i
said
call on people by name if i ask the room
are there any questions it will be
followed with silence
sometimes that silence means nobody has
any questions
sometimes that silence means people have
questions but they don't want to look
foolish
and sometimes that silence means they're
very busy typing
and the question is going to pop up in
15 seconds by which point i will
probably have moved on
instead when i want somebody to
contribute
i call on them by name and if they want
to pass if they say i don't have an
answer i don't feel like
this is the right time that's fine i'll
move on to the next person
calling on people by name also helps you
level out your classroom you are about
to discover
that some of your learners think much
more quickly
than others that doesn't mean they're
smarter
doesn't mean they're producing better
work it just means that their first
response comes
faster if you are calling on people by
name
you can even that out by throwing
softballs to people who might need a
little bit more time
throwing harder questions at people who
are a little quicker
and that way the whole class is
progressing at about the same rate
this is all a lot to manage so this
brings us to the other big takeaway
don't teach alone if you can possibly
avoid it
don't be the only person trying to run
things
every great surgeon has a great nurse
beside her
every great teacher has a co-teacher it
could be
a fellow instructor it could be a ta it
could be one of your learners
that you've approached to say you seem
to be
okay with this material can i ask you a
favor whoever it is
you want somebody else keeping track of
whose turn it is to speak next
somebody else making sure that the
slides are presenting properly
somebody else who is wrangling that
shared document that we're going to talk
about in a couple of minutes
you want a co-pilot who's worrying about
everything
that isn't the actual delivery of the
lesson in the moment
to free you up to focus on your slides
and what you're saying
i've got that right now and it makes a
world of difference
it doesn't take a lot of practice to
learn how to do that
and it does also mean that
if next week you're unable to make a
scheduled class
for whatever reason there's somebody
else who's
at least partly familiar with what
you're teaching and with how you're
delivering it
so do a dry run
i have a list someplace of things that
have gone wrong
while i've been teaching i've fallen off
stage twice and concussed myself once
i've had
a fistfight breakout i've had a
projector catch fire
i've had i've had a woman go into labor
and i once actually fell asleep in one
of my own lectures
those are the easy ones the hard one is
nobody told me there was a firewall
so all of a sudden i can't get at any of
the data sets
nobody told me that they've updated zoom
and some of the controls have moved or
behaved differently
or i know all of that but i've never
done it
with robert i've never done it with
carina
and so we're used to using the tool in
different ways
getting 10 or 15 minutes half an hour
before you're supposed to start talking
can make a world of difference to
delivery and it can lower your blood
pressure considerably
okay
another small note um keep your notes
beside you
um i've got a laptop
on my desk and then i've got a large
screen monitor above it i think that's a
fairly common setup these days
what that meant was that going back a
while whenever i was teaching i was
looking
up and had my head tilted back and my
daughter eventually told me that as far
as she was concerned my webcam was a
nose cam and that's why i don't have a
picture for this slide
if you've got your notes beside you it's
very natural to turn your head to the
side
check what you're going to say next and
come back to your lecture
if you've got the slides up here it's
not something you're used to doing
and the angle can be rather unflattering
i know it's a small thing
but the small things add up
a much larger thing please add speakers
notes to your slides
you are about to discover that a lot of
your learners
have trouble seeing or hearing they've
got good compensating strategies or
accommodation strategies in a live
classroom because they've got a lifetime
of experience doing this
they may not have the same support now
that you're bailing everything online
if you put speakers notes in your slides
it makes the slides
more findable because search tools know
how to index them
it makes the slides more usable because
people can understand after the fact
what you meant by that picture but
crucially it makes them more accessible
and however hard you think life is
suddenly being thrown online it's a lot
harder
if you're partially sighted or fully
deaf
please don't make life harder for people
who already have more to struggle with
in fact using accessibility tools helps
everyone
i don't know if you can see my cursor
right now
but i've used the accessibility tools on
the mac to make it as large as possible
so that it's easier for people to see on
video
i do that whenever i'm teaching i use an
enlarged cursor
because a small cursor in a small window
is
really really hard to see i switched to
high contrast mode
so that people who might be sizing down
the screen
or might be on older devices or might
just have crappy monitors
have a better chance of being able to
see what's going on
all of these tools help in key casting
tools
that will show people on screen all of
the
control keys option keys and other
things that you're typing
you should be using those anyway when
you're teaching
so that somebody doesn't think you're
typing 100 characters a second they
realize that you hit tab and got file
name completion
key caster is one that you can use most
pose is another there's a lot of
accessibility tools out there
most of them are either free or very
cheap
most of them are fairly easy to set up
and they will all help with your online
teaching
and when you're done keep using them
when you go back in the classroom
because they'll make life better for
everyone
this recommendation comes again from
elizabeth wicks
teach from your smallest screen
if i try to take my half meter wide
monitor
and squeeze it down into a little video
window
the video quality is going to be pretty
grainy and the bandwidth demands are
going to be pretty heavy
i'm not suggesting that you teach from a
tiny handheld device like this
but please remember that most of your
learners will be using smaller and
older gear than you've got
you want to be at the bottom of the pack
when you're the one sending out the
video
because that has the greatest chance of
working everywhere
and i'll add a personal footnote to this
it's
difficult to teach with an
ide when you're screen sharing because
once you've sized things down
all of the controls in the ide for
different tabs different menus and so
forth all of those things that are
really helpful
they're taking up a lot of space and you
don't have a lot of
leftover real estate for your own typing
i have seen people put our studio ide
into a mode where only one pane is being
shown at a time
that's great from a real estate point of
view but now it looks very different
from what people
are used to i don't have a solution for
this one ask your learners what they
prefer
circling back to a topic from a few
minutes ago your voice matters more than
your face
you can switch off video or you can go
to still images like this one
and give a decent class you cannot lose
voice or voice quality
and still have a decent class
my setup is a samsung microphone
and a 25 dollar stand from my local
music store
i got the stand so that the microphone
would be far enough away from the
keyboard
that it wouldn't be filled with all the
clicking as i type
you can still hear the clicking but it's
a soft background noise
rather than thunder again
try out your rig with your co-instructor
or with some randomly selected student
or if you don't have anybody else mail
me and i will listen to it
but getting the mic up level with your
head
about 30 centimeters away from your
mouth
and away from your keyboard and that's
as much as you need to do now
if later on you want to go get spit
guards and swaffles and do
the full rig absolutely knock yourself
out but you don't need to do that first
week
what you do need to do is turn off your
notifications
it you don't want
things popping up on screen constantly
telling you that you've got mail
that you've got something on twitter you
should be looking at
i turn slack off completely whenever i'm
teaching
unless i'm using it to communicate with
my students
because it's just a distraction and you
can
ask them to turn theirs off as well
i know that most won't i mean if you go
into a
in-person classroom stand at the back
and look over people's shoulders
at any given time about a third of them
are doing something on their laptop
some of it is course related some of it
isn't
once they're in an online environment
there's going to be more of that
but it's worth asking again if you've
got a focus group of about half a dozen
that you're directing most of your
teaching to
they're more likely to switch off
distractions and actually be engaged
because they're being called on with
higher frequency
so you can get a high quality experience
for a small
group and everybody else is going to do
what they would do anyway
now we come to that shared doc that i've
been talking about
excuse me a second i need a mouthful of
tea
every time i teach online i create
something like a google doc
or a hackmd if for those of you who love
markdown
and i give edit permission to the people
i'm teaching
whenever i ask a question and want a
response from everybody
i now have options i can either tell
them
put it in the chat which i will do if
i'm looking for a one word or two word
response
or if i'm asking something a little
larger and they need
to show me a bit of code write a couple
of sentences
something like that they paste it into
the document
i say paste it in because a lot of
people don't want you to see them
typing i'm comfortable with that but
i've been doing this for years
what i see a lot of newcomers do is have
a separate text editor
where they're composing their answer to
question number three
and then they'll copy it and they'll
just paste it into the google doc
that's cool as they become more
comfortable
maybe they'll do their editing directly
in the dock so that others can see their
mistakes and see them being corrected
that's cool too the important thing is
that it allows
you to see their work in real time and
it allows them to see one another's work
in real time
that dramatically improves engagement
and you get a lot of peer-to-peer
learning
if you ask people to for example
find the height of the tallest person in
louisiana
in 1920 using a deep plier pipeline
there are three or four plausible ways
to arrange the commands to do that
each person will have one and then
they'll be able to glance at a few
others in the document and go oh
that's cool it's exactly like what we do
in a music class where i say okay janet
you play this piece okay now janine you
play this piece
we're used to seeing and hearing others
work in live context
we can do that online and this is
probably the
the biggest change in my teaching
practice
over the last 10 years is trusting
learners to share work with each other
in real time
a couple of caveats for this number one
if you're going to do it keep that list
of half a dozen names or
the entire class name depending on how
many are contributing to the doc
paste it into the doc before they start
typing and do that for each
question so that everybody knows where
they're supposed to start typing
if you say just add this to the dock
you'll have two dozen people putting
their cursors on top of each other
and colliding with one another's work
that's not helpful
they'll very quickly opt out because
it's frustrating if on the other hand
i've got a list of names with a couple
of blank lines between them in a text
file
and i paste it into the dock everybody
immediately knows where to type and
there's no collisions
the second thing has to do with scope
google doc will comfortably support
14 or 15 maybe 16 concurrent typists
it won't support 30 you'll see a sudden
dramatic slow down
at some threshold and i've never done
the experiments to measure where it is
but it's somewhere between a dozen and
twenty
again you solve this problem by having a
subset of people contributing to the
shared
document and swapping that up each time
you take a coffee break each time you
restart your class
talked about this before keep track of
who has and hasn't spoken
to make sure that the people who aren't
extroverts are getting airtime
it doesn't have to be electronic just a
piece of paper and a pencil beside you
putting tick marks in trying to make
sure that you distribute your attention
fairly so that everybody feels like
they're
not just allowed in the room but they're
welcome in the room
ask phil call is a pretty common tactic
from
the days of broadcast radio if i ask a
question
it's going to take people a while to
formulate an answer
if i'm asking them for a long answer
three lines of code for example it's
probably going to take them 15 seconds
and
even a gap of 7 seconds which you just
heard can be really uncomfortable
so if i want somebody to come in with a
question
i ask the question and then as they're
composing their answer
i fill the error i say something else i
elaborate on a previous point
they'll probably tune me out while they
focus on their answer
so it can't be anything too important
but it's like
it's like making small talk while
somebody is setting the table
you want to ask your question you want
to fill in a little bit so that there's
not dead air
and then you want to say okay sarah now
what have you got for us
again you're doing this to make up for
the lack of social cues
you don't have that peripheral awareness
of people's attention
so you're going to have to be more
directive
another way that you can take advantage
of the online teaching is to ask people
for predictions
this is particularly important when
you're teaching coding
if i'm teaching a programming class i'm
probably
sharing my screen so that you can see
the code as i'm building it
every time i'm about to do something i
have an opportunity to say all right
everybody
in the chat what's going to happen if i
run it now
i've just added this line how is it
going to behave
pedagogically this is forcing people to
pull recent knowledge
back into consciousness and use it and
reinforce it
that will help them learn and remember
from a motivational point of view
it increases their engagement they're
constantly being asked to think and to
contribute
and from your point of view it gives you
a very
quick formative assessment for those who
don't know the term
formative assessment is what you do
during learning
to find out whether or not people are
learning
it's your real-time feedback loop you
cannot trust
people to go uh-huh got it i got it
because a lot of people will lie
they'll say they have it when they don't
or they'll believe that they do but
they'll be wrong
and they're even more likely to mislead
this way
when you're teaching online if on the
other hand i say all right
paul and ahmed what's this going to do
next
if they're right you know that they're
understanding
if they're wrong then you know that
you've got something to explain to
clarify or to cover a second time
and you can do it right then and there
before their misconception
has a chance to set in concrete
this is a point where i would normally
pull my class
to say how many of you know braco ribs
for those of you who don't
if you're using something like zoom
you can go down and put everybody into a
small
sub conversation you can assign them
manually
or you can assign them at random you can
vary the size of the rooms
and you can determine how long they're
in that side conversation
here's a question the answer isn't
obvious
everybody go and think about it and then
argue with your three partners
and see if you can come to a consensus
about what this code does
or doesn't do three two one go
you've got a couple of minutes and then
i pull you back
and i pull a couple of people
this emulates a practice called peer
instruction
which is the most effective scalable
teaching practice we know
the slide deck has a link to a video
from a math class in india in 2013
that illustrates the method short
version is
i ask a motivating question something
whose answer requires more than just
factual recall you all then go and argue
with each other over the answer
and then i pull you back and give you
the explanation why the argument stage
because that's when you have to think
through the inconsistencies or gaps in
your mental model
and you've got other people there who
can fill them in
one of the great discoveries is it
doesn't really matter if anybody in one
of these little discussion groups is
right at the start what matters is that
you disagree
so that you can clear up each other's
misconceptions
pedagogically it's a well-justified
method practically it also helps with
motivation
because instead of only teaching to half
a dozen for
half an hour you can teach to that half
dozen
and then say okay now everybody's going
into a small discussion group
and then i'm bringing you back and now
they have to interact with their peers
again you want people to be able to opt
out
they may not be in a situation where
they can have a conversation
they might be in the living room muted
because the entire family is here at the
moment
you've got to respect that some people
may be uncomfortable
arguing with strangers at the outset of
a class you respect that
but for everyone else it's a very
effective technique
one of the things that we can't do
with any of any video tool i have today
is put people into breakout rooms in
which they can all
screen share with each other i would
really like to be able to put people
into pairs
and have them screen share so they can
co-program
the technology will get there eventually
but something
like that or a shared whiteboard in the
breakout room
would probably help a lot we just have
to wait
and since i mentioned whiteboards zoom
provides
polls so that you can ask people
questions in real time and do a
survey it also provides a whiteboard
don't try to use it yet become
comfortable with the online teaching
sort out some of your other problems and
then start to try to take advantage of
all the science fiction you've been
handed
you don't need it today take advantage
of it tomorrow
the quote here comes from my wife who
once explained to me that the basic unit
of teaching is the bladder
and i said i've never thought of it that
way and she said you've never been
pregnant
you need to take a break every hour your
back's going to get sore your voice is
going to get hoarse
your learners are probably in situations
that are no more comfortable than yours
and quite probably less and even when
they're comfortable
it's a long day and it's a lot of coffee
make sure that you set yourself a timer
i do it on my phone
and have it go off at 45 minutes
i found that when i was setting timers
for an hour because i always drift a
little over
we were only taking breaks about every
75 or 80 minutes
if i set the timer for 45 minutes i'm
pretty much guaranteed a break every
hour
whatever i set it for i always go over
five or ten minutes
okay and to wrap up before we start
taking questions
i want you all to know that nobody knows
anything
right now we've been teaching online
in relatively small numbers
in relatively constrained technological
environments
for a couple of decades
maybe three and on the one hand that
sounds like a lot
but on the other we are about to invent
more different ways to teach online in
the next 12 months
then we know in total today because
we're about to do a whole lot of
experiments
you're going to suck at this at first
but that's a necessary first step
towards being good at it
don't beat yourself up and
don't be afraid to experiment don't be
afraid to try
things and then to say all right that
didn't work
i think everybody understands that these
are unusual circumstances
i think everybody i hope is is going to
give people a little bit of slack give
them a little bit of allowance
because of the unusual circumstances so
there's never been a better time to try
new things
your audience will never be more
understanding
and as i said at the outset we're here
to help if there's anything
we can do if there's any questions you
have
throw them at us
last thing before we dive into the
clothes
if you've got time to do any reading i
highly recommend
this book by brookfield and preschool
i've been talking about things with
people
in large groups since i was about 16
of the 50 different techniques they
catalog in this book
for having a productive discussion i had
only ever seen
15 and i've only ever seen five or six
implemented online
this is a catalog of ways to get people
to talk to one another
and share information and make decisions
a lot of them are directly applicable to
teaching
and even if you don't have direct
customized technical support
they're all social conventions that are
fairly easy to adopt in an online
environment
just to pick one example suppose i've
got half a dozen people that i'm
focusing on
all right i want all of you to put your
answers to this question into the google
doc
okay now that we've got those i want you
each to shift down one spot
bottom person comes to the top and
comment on
the answer from the person that you're
now looking at
okay now shift down one more so now
you're looking at an answer
and a previous set of comments
people will learn so much from each
other and the peer-to-peer knowledge
transfer
will make up for so much of what you're
losing by not having them physically
present
and that's just one idea in a book full
of 50.
so here are some links that i found
useful preparing this
jason bell in australia who i believe is
here with us today
has a good video on what it's like to
teach software carpentry workshops
remotely
he's in queensland a lot of his learners
are scattered so he's had to figure out
over the years
how you teach programming when you are
hundreds of kilometers away
from all of your learners and they're
hundreds of kilometers away from each
other
elizabeth wicks i've cited a couple of
times has a really good set of tips
for teaching on tech subjects online
there's a growing number of comments in
the r studio community teaching
discussion you're all welcome to join in
there
i'm a big fan of the piece that laura
schernawicz wrote
in south africa what they learned from
going online in cape town
on short notice that link
there includes a sub link to a document
about how to accommodate
wildly different technical levels among
your students
they'll have differential access to
devices to bandwidth
a whole bunch of things they've got a
lot of experience
about how you accommodate that so please
follow that one up
and finally just today there was another
blog post from the carpentries
they're collecting their tips for
teaching online and again there are
links out to other resources
so with all of that done i am hoping
that some people will have
questions so leon justin's saying that
calling people by name
is referred to as harpooning and
discouraged yes
like any teaching technique it can be
used badly
you risk lower tier and introvert
students leaving the teaching platform
because they don't want to be called out
i respect that normally
you can detect that or you can ask them
in advance
to message you if they are uncomfortable
being called on just have them tell you
right and and respect whatever it is
they do
alissa dillman's looking for a list of
accessibility tools
yes we've got a blog post hopefully up
sometime next week
um does a cardioid mic help reduce the
keyboard noise it can um
this samson isn't a cardioid i just got
it by trial and error i've got it tilted
at an angle where it seems to just pick
up my voice and not the keyboard
for those who don't know the term a
cardioid mic picks up sound on one side
or the other but not in between right
it's a directional microphone intended
primarily for
interviews where you've got two people
on opposite sides of a mic
one of the reason i got the samson is
that it's a cheap enough microphone that
if i lose it while traveling i'm not
heartbroken
a good cardioid mic is going to be more
expensive
laura asian feel lost reading all the
feedback from the students in a shared
doc
do you have any tips to read the
feedback this is part of what your
co-instructor can
do for you normally when i'm teaching i
will call out
one or two but i've got somebody else
there just as i've had robert and curtis
going through your questions and
flagging them
right so that by the time i get there
somebody else has already done the first
pass of filtering
um ryan davis for smaller class doing
quick intros at the start
absolutely if you've got the time if
they're comfortable doing it
um and then kelsey carrier do you have a
tactic for keeping track of participant
responses
when they may have strange or
unrecognizable names
yes i
i sometimes now have learners whose name
field
is an emoji in those cases i will
ask people can you please change it for
the duration of the session or just let
me know how to address you
i find that asking people how do you
want to be addressed also helps
with internationalization of names and
pronouns
i'm quite often not sure which of the
several parts of someone's name the most
usual
most used to being called by
particularly when i get into east asian
and south asian cultures
that i'm not familiar with and it's
always a good idea
to ask people what pronoun they would
like you to use
students don't turn on their video
because they don't feel comfortable
uh this one's coming from gabby sandoval
in many cases they don't turn it on
because they're busy with other things
now they don't want you to see that they
are also doing their calculus homework
while they're supposed to be in your
class i ask them
i try to create an environment in which
they're comfortable being seen
focusing on a small number at a time
does seem to help with this
i think it's partly a matter of trust
i'm afraid i don't have anything more
specific than that that i can recommend
i think people are going to become more
comfortable in a hurry
as we all start doing a lot more online
in a hurry
lynn williams how do you work with
google hot docs and hack md when it's
new to your class
and they've said it's use is
overwhelming really good question
i don't use it on day one i will
sometimes for instructor training
because
we've only got day one but in a lot of
other circumstances
i'm going to introduce these practices
to people one at a time
over the course of several lessons first
day
just get them used to using zoom and
taking turns speaking because that's the
most important thing
second class with them get them used to
the idea
that when i ask a question they can all
give short responses in chat
it's not archived it'll fly by i
probably don't even read all of them but
i'm getting used to them
getting them used to contributing things
like a focus group things like turning
on their own video
things like using the google doc
lesson two lesson three okay coming down
a bit
how do you make sure each student is
paying attention you can't
we and this is from matthias we can't do
it in person either
i remember very clearly being in an
electrical engineering class watching a
colleague teach
and since i was standing at the back and
looking down these rows of seats
i could see that almost a third of the
students were playing poker online
during the lecture
we're not going to do better than that
when we shift them all online
okay what we can do is
is the best we can with the tools we
have
um karina marks
whereby.com skype for business microsoft
teams i like whereby dot com
a lot for those of you who haven't seen
it it uses
modern web standards like webrtc it's a
beautiful little tool
i think skype for business is a really
good advertisement for zoom
i was on a skype call tuesday night for
the first time in ages with my guitar
teacher
and we're going to try zoom next time i
haven't used microsoft
teams i'd be interested in other
people's experience of using it as a
teaching platform
is there a way to help teach us how to
use zoom if we never have from michelle
connor
okay if you mail me i'm greg.wilson
rstudio.com
we'll set up a session we'll show you
what we know
um other recommended platforms for video
calls from arena july's cabasis
i'm in toronto canada i know what works
here
i would be very grateful from comments
from other people about what has worked
where they are i i don't know what a
good video conferencing solution is
in argentina or malaysia or south africa
i don't want to give you misleading
information but please throw it into the
rstudio community channel
or throw it to me and i'll share it why
is dead air so bad
a couple of moments of quiet time after
hearing a question
is fine but a couple of moments really
does mean a couple of moments
people will become very
uncomfortable with a silence like the
one i just did
right if they've got video and can see
that you're still there
that reduces it a bit but it
is still uncomfortable to have a long
pause
and jeremiah is asking these are great
but many ideas relate to live or ace
or synchronous teaching with my students
scattered this won't work any advice on
making asynchronous teaching compelling
that one's actually easier to do online
because you're already doing a lot of it
you're probably already publishing your
slides
you're probably already using some sort
of homework submission
system you probably hopefully already
have some sort of discussion forum or
board or mailing list set up for your
class
that stuff won't change if your
administration is pushing you
to record and publish videos on short
notice
please push back it's a lot of work
if you're worried about burning up
particularly now that you're juggling
everything else
that's going to be the one that breaks
you if you're
already doing async teaching with
text and images and static documents
that's the way you want to run
leon jessen i could see it was online
and during the four hour class i lost
some of the lower tier students
so leon i would ask did they drop out
because it was a four hour class four
hours is a long time
in one chunk i mean human attention is
45 to 90 minutes without a reset
i think if you're putting people into a
four hour class you're going to lose
people for a whole bunch of reasons
i couldn't do it these days because of
my back i simply can't sit in a chair
for four hours ago the second question
is would be when you say lower tier do
you mean
people who are less advanced people who
have less technical skill
or have a less solid grasp of the
material in which case
they were checking out in your in-person
class as well
it just wasn't as obvious they were
physically present
but mentally they had checked out and
now you're seeing it
and one of the things that we get from
people logging out of
zoom logging out of video calls is that
we can actually see who's checking out
in a way that we couldn't before it's
not creating the problem necessarily
it's revealing it and that may sound
like i'm making an
excuse or trying to explain it away the
honest truth is i don't know
and i don't know of any research on this
amateur ditko do you have any tips to
notice quickly when you're losing
someone during a training
pair them up with them in groups as
quickly as possible so that their peers
can support them breakout rooms
pairwise discussions having them review
each other's work in a shared document
things like that you can't give
individual attention to a dozen people
at once never mind a class of 50.
they can give attention to each other
the one thing that you have to monitor
is that they're not being trolls
provided
attendance is named not anonymous
you've got some sort of control over
that but if you have 50 people
anonymously in a classroom giving each
other feedback
somebody's going to be rude to somebody
and then you've lost a learner
so i strongly prefer that people
identify themselves and i think
since most of us are working in formal
educational context either
university classroom or a paid training
event it's okay to ask for real names
uh jeffrey thompson we're doing async
instruction recording short videos
have students watch them and then
holding virtual office hours
great this is the equivalent of a
flipped classroom
flipped classroom is one where the
students learn the material out of class
and do the homework in class
so that when they're actually trying to
apply the knowledge you're right there
with them when they need you most
have them work through problems in that
shared session
ask one of them to share their screen
and actually
solve a small programming problem or if
they've got a tablet and a fingertip
to work out an equation there in front
of people you would bring somebody up
and have them do work on a whiteboard
in an in-person class you would have
somebody play a passage on a saxophone
in a band class
you can do that to improve engagement
and to
take full advantage of the interactivity
of those office hours
okay skipping down again um
tips for engaging when there are many
many students
all right something i should have
emphasized more during the presentation
you are not going to be able to do
better
in the next three months shifting online
then you're doing right now
in person one person lecturing to a
class of a thousand
is a poor learning experience it doesn't
matter if it's online or not
peer instruction goes a long way towards
addressing that
getting them talking to each other in
small groups periodically to clear up
each other's misconceptions
is a proven scalable approach to this
but if you're trying to take
broadcast instruction where you're the
one delivering information to all of
them
in an in-person class a lot of them
aren't engaged and a lot of them are
lost
you just don't realize it so we're not
going to be able to do better
right away my goal for the next 90 days
is is just not to do worse
coming down to a couple of others
because we're almost out of time
excuse me some more questions
about async teaching um can you talk
about adding captions to live streamed
content on zoom absolutely
um i add speakers notes to the slide
deck
rather than captioning the live streamed
content
because i find that's easier for people
to search
i don't have a lot of experience with
adding captions to live streamed content
if you can throw that question to me by
email i'll go and find somebody who's
done this more than i have
and we will come back and give you an
answer
lisa johnson any advice for sticky note
substitutions for participants to give
feedback
on the pace for those of you who don't
know
a trick pioneered in the carpentry's
workshops is to give everybody a green
sticky and a red sticky
green sticky means things are going okay
red sticky means
i've got a problem i need help in zoom
people can set an icon thumbs up thumbs
down
you know how am i feeling about this
right now it's kind of hard for you as
the teacher to monitor those
so that's something your co-pilot can do
i wish there were better controls or
something a little more adaptive to
indicate
but you can use thumbs up thumbs down
and zoom i don't know if there's a
similar capability
in go to meeting go to webinar rather
coming down a little further
software for online teaching pick a
video conferencing tool
pick a wiki tool or use google docs
pick something for real-time chat it can
be slack or
anything else i don't recommend
any of the custom integrated tools most
learning management systems are actually
grading management systems they don't
really help with the learning and the
interactive experience lisa johnson
do you have audio tips to tips for audio
issues where more than one student has
something to say at the same time
mute everybody and then you invite
somebody into the conversation
parliamentary rules nobody speaks unless
the speaker calls on them
when you're doing that your job as the
teacher becomes that as
more of a traffic director you're
deciding who speaks next
and why it doesn't take very long for
people to get used to it
and if you're proactive about muting
everybody they'll pretty quickly learn
that they're not going to be allowed to
break that rule
how do you deal with trolls sudhir
shukla
really important question you deal with
them the same way that you would in an
in-person class
you start by reminding everybody that
there is a code of conduct and certain
rules are expected to be followed
everybody gets one warning they may not
understand that they've transgressed
after that yes absolutely shut them down
mute them and leave them muted disable
their access to the dock
i recommend that you don't kick them out
of the room
so that they're unable to see your
presentation
because then they might go and complain
to somebody but
take away their ability to impede
other people's learning experience as
soon as is a troll
your responsibility is no longer to them
it's to all of your other learners